a progressive web app or pwa will make
a traditional web application behave
more like a native mobile app
in this episode we're going to take an
angular 4 application and make it 100
compliant with google's pwa spec
to do this we're going to create an app
manifest with a bunch of mobile icons
we're going to cache our app offline
with a service worker and we're going to
serve it over a secure https connection
when that's all said and done we'll be
able to run our app through the
lighthouse chrome plugin which is
maintained by google
which will tell us whether or not we're
meeting all the pwa requirements as well
as give us some feedback on performance
and best practices
not only will this provide a better user
experience but it will also bring up
this ad to home screen banner on
android devices or any other program
that supports progressive web apps
currently it's not supported in ios
safari or microsoft edge but they are
moving in that direction so they
probably will be supported in the future
another cool feature we're not going to
talk about in this video is push
notifications but i do have another
video covering that topic so make sure
to check that out as well
the first step is to install the
lighthouse plugin for chrome you can get
it in the chrome store
and it's what we're going to use to
generate the actual audit
on the site the next step is to create
the manifest.json file in the source
directory of your project
the purpose of this file is to tell
browsers exactly how to handle your web
app
for example your app should have a name
and some theme colors
and you'll also want to tell it whether
or not to display in portrait or
landscape then we need to generate some
icons there's plenty of places on the
internet where you can have this all
done automatically with just a single
base
logo you need to have a variety of icons
to handle different mobile devices and
operating systems
after you generate the icons drop them
into your assets folder in angular
and then add them to the manifest each
icon will need to have its own source
size and type specified that's it for
the manifest there's plenty of other
things we could add here but this is the
bare minimum that we need for now
the next thing we need to do is link our
manifest in the index.html as well as
provide some other meta tags
we have a variety of meta tags here that
are basically all telling different
browsers that our
site is mobile app capable then the only
other thing we need to do
is link to the manifest that we just
created we also need to register it in
the angular cli
so we can do that by adding it to the
assets array to ensure it's in our
production build that's it for the first
part of the process
now we need to start building a service
worker that will cache the page
for offline capabilities this diagram
shows the basic process
the service worker will cache the assets
on the user's device
and if the internet is out then it will
serve up whatever's in the cache to give
the user some interactivity when there's
no connection
you can actually test this out now on
our live fire starter demo app
first visit the app with an active
connection and then turn off the
internet connection
and refresh the page the website on the
left has no offline cache so it just
gets the standard error
while firestarter on the right has an
offline cache with the service worker so
it gets a full web page displayed anyway
to implement this feature we can
actually pick up right where we left off
in the index.html
we'll go down to the closing body tag
and we're going to write a script that
will register the service worker
it's extremely simple it just checks if
the navigator has a service worker
and if so it calls
serviceworker.register followed by the
service worker name
currently the serviceworker.js file
doesn't exist but we're going to use a
package called
sw precache to build it automatically in
the next step
sw precache is a popular open source
library developed by google that we're
going to use to write the service worker
code for us automatically
first we install the webpack version of
the library to our development
environment using mpm
then create a new file called
precacheconfig.js
in the root of your project inside the
file we first import sw precache and
then we'll set our configuration
variables
i'd like to point out that the navigate
fallback whitelist is necessary if
you're using firebase oauth
so don't forget to include it if you are
sw precache is going to create the
service worker right after our
production build is created in the dist
folder
in this example we're going to cache all
javascript and css assets
but you can customize this any way you
want based on your own app configuration
to use this script we're going to create
a custom command in the package.json
file
we create a command called pwa for
progressive web app
it first runs ng build production and
then it runs sw
precache in the dist folder where that
production build lives
and uses the configuration that we just
supplied
then from the command line we can just
run npm run
pwa as you can see it does our normal
production build with ahead of time
compilation
and then after that's done it generates
the service worker
now let's actually go into the disk
folder and take a look at the service
worker
we have an array of a bunch of cached
assets that will be served when the app
is offline
then we have a bunch of event listeners
in this file that will handle the
management of the cache for the user
as well as trigger that install banner
on compatible devices
the only thing left to do is deploy the
app it's required that your app be
served over an https connection with an
ssl certificate if you're deploying with
firebase this is configured
automatically
but any other hosting over https should
work
if you are using firebase just run
firebase deploy only hosting
and then we can validate everything with
the lighthouse plugin
you use the plugin by just clicking it
and running generate report it's really
that easy
at this point our app is scoring 100 on
the pwa score which means it's
installable on compatible devices
but every app's different so you may
have other issues you have to address
beyond this
if you get stuck anywhere make sure to
join our slack team and we'll be more
than happy to help you out
if this video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want to support the
channel consider becoming a pro member
at angularfirebase.com
you'll get a free copy of my book as
well as one-on-one project consulting
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next time
you